i'm a marine biologist
here to talk to you about the crisis in
our oceans
but this time perhaps not with a message
you've heard before
because i want to tell you that if the
survival of the oceans depended
only on people like me scientists
trading in publications we'd be in even
worse trouble than we are
because as a scientist the most
important things that i've learned
about keeping our oceans healthy and
productive
have come not from academia but from
fishermen and women
living in some of the poorest countries
on earth i've learned that as a
conservationist
the most important question is not how
do we keep people out
but rather how do we make sure that
coastal people
throughout the world have enough to eat
our oceans are every bit as critical to
our own survival
as our atmosphere our forests or our
soils
their staggering productivity ranks
fisheries with farming as a mainstay
of food production for humanity yet
something's gone badly wrong
we're accelerating into an extinction
emergency one that my field
has so far failed abysmally to tackle
at its core is a very human and
humanitarian crisis
the most devastating blow we've so far
dealt our oceans is through
overfishing every year we fish harder
deeper
further afield every year we chase ever
fewer fish
yet the crisis of overfishing is a great
paradox
unnecessary avoidable and entirely
reversible
because fisheries are one of the most
productive resources
on the planet with the right strategies
we can
reverse overfishing that we've not yet
done so is
to my mind one of humanity's greatest
failures nowhere is this failure
more apparent than in the warm waters on
either side of our equator
our tropics are home to most of the
species in our ocean
most of the people whose existence
depends on our seas
we call these coastal fishermen and
women small scale fishers
but small scales a misnomer for a fleet
comprising over 90 percent of the
world's fishermen
and women their fishing is generally
more selective
and sustainable than the indiscriminate
destruction
too often wrought by bigger industrial
boats
these coastal people have the most to
gain from conservation because for many
of them
fishing is all that keeps them from
poverty
hunger or forced migration in countries
where the state
is often unable to help we know that the
outlook is grim
stocks collapsing on the front lines of
climate change
warming seas dying reefs catastrophic
storms
trawlers factory fleets rapacious
ships from richer countries taking more
than their share
extreme vulnerability is the new normal
i first landed on the island of
madagascar two decades ago
on a mission to document its marine
natural history i was mesmerized
by the coral reefs i explored and
certain i knew how to protect them
because science provided all the answers
close
areas of the reef permanently coastal
fishers simply needed to fish less
i approached elders here in the village
of andavadoc
and recommended that they close off the
healthiest and most diverse coral reefs
to all forms of fishing
to form a refuge to help stocks recover
because
as the science tells us after five or so
years
fish populations inside those refuges
would be much bigger
replenishing the fished areas outside
making everybody better off
that conversation didn't go so well
three-quarters of madagascar's 27
million people live on less than two
dollars a day
my earnest appeal to fishless took no
account of what that might actually mean
for people who depend on fishing for
survival it was just
another squeeze from outside a
restriction rather than a solution
what does protecting a long list of
latin species names mean to resacks
a woman from andavadoc who fishes every
day to put food on the table
and send her grandchildren to school
that initial rejection taught me that
conservation is
at its core a journey in listening
deeply to understand the pressures and
realities that communities face
through their dependence on nature this
idea became
the founding principle for my work and
grew into an organization that brought
a new approach to ocean conservation by
working to rebuild fisheries
with coastal communities then
as now the work started by listening and
what we learned astonished us
back in the dry south of madagascar we
learned that one species was immensely
important for villagers
this remarkable octopus we learned that
soaring demand was depleting
an economic lifeline but we also learned
that this animal grows astonishingly
fast
doubling in weight every one or two
months
we reasoned that protecting just a small
area of fishing ground
for just a few months might lead to
dramatic
increases in catches enough to make a
difference
to this community's bottom line in a
time frame that might
just be acceptable the community thought
so too
opting to close a small area of reef to
octopus fishing
temporarily using a customary social
code
invoking blessings from the ancestors to
prevent poaching
when that reef reopened to fishing six
months later
none of us were prepared for what
happened next catches
soared with men and women landing more
and bigger octopus
than anyone had seen for years
neighbouring villages saw the fishing
boom and drew up their own closures
spreading the model virally
along hundreds of miles of coastline
when we ran the numbers
we saw that these communities among the
poorest on earth had found a way
to double their money in a matter of
months by fishing
less imagine a savings account from
which you withdraw half your balance
every year and your savings keep
growing there is no investment
opportunity
on earth that can reliably deliver what
fisheries can
but the real magic went beyond profit
because a far deeper transformation was
happening in these communities
spurred on by rising catches leaders
from andavadoc joined force with two
dozen neighboring communities
to establish a vast conservation area
along dozens of miles of coastline they
outlawed fishing with poison
and mosquito nets and set aside
permanent refuges
around threatened coral reefs and
mangroves including
to my astonishment those same sites that
i'd flagged
just two years earlier when my
evangelism for marine protection
was so roundly rejected they created a
community-led
protected area a democratic system for
local marine governance that was
totally unimaginable just a few years
earlier
and they didn't stop there within five
years they'd secured legal rights from
the state
to manage over 200 square miles of ocean
eliminating destructive industrial
trawlers
from the waters ten years on we're
seeing recovery
of those critical reefs within those
refuges communities are petitioning for
greater recognition of the right to fish
and fairer prices that reward
sustainability
but all that is just the beginning of
the story
because this handful of fishing villages
taking action
has sparked a marine conservation
revolution that has spread over
thousands of miles
impacting hundreds of thousands of
people today in madagascar
hundreds of sites are managed by
communities applying this human
rights-based approach to conservation
to all kinds of fisheries from mud crabs
to mackerel
the models crossed borders through east
africa
and the indian ocean and is now island
hopping into southeast asia
from tanzania to timor-leste from india
to indonesia we're seeing the same story
unfold
that when we design it right marine
conservation reaps dividends that go far
beyond protecting nature
improving catches and driving waves of
social change
along entire coastlines strengthening
confidence cooperation
and the resilience of communities to
face the injustice of poverty
and climate change i've been privileged
to spend my career catalyzing and
connecting these movements
throughout the tropics and i've learned
that as conservationists our goal must
be to win
at scale not just to lose more slowly
we need to step up to this global
opportunity
to rebuild fisheries with field workers
to stand with communities and connect
them to support them to act and learn
from one another
with governments and lawyers standing
with communities to secure their rights
to manage their fisheries prioritizing
local food
and job security above all competing
interests
in the ocean economy ending subsidies
for grotesquely over capitalized
industrial fleets
and keeping those industrial and foreign
vessels out
of coastal waters we need agile data
systems that put science in the hands of
communities
to optimize conservation to the target
species
or habitat we need development agencies
donors and the conservation
establishment to raise their ambition
to the scale of investment urgently
required
to deliver this vision and to get there
we all need to reimagine marine
conservation
as a narrative of abundance and
empowerment
not of austerity and alienation a
movement
guided by the people who depend on
healthy seas for their survival
not by abstract scientific values
of course fixing overfishing is just one
step to fixing our oceans
the horrors of warming acidification
and pollution grow each day but it's a
big step
it's one we can take today and it's one
that will give a much needed boost
to those exploring scalable solutions to
other dimensions of our ocean emergency
our success propels theirs
if we throw up our hands in despair it's
game
over we solve these challenges by taking
them on
one by one our overwhelming dependence
on our ocean
is the solution that has been hiding in
plain sight
because there's nothing small about
small-scale fishes
they're a hundred million strong and
provide nutrition to billions
it's this army of everyday
conservationists
who have the most at stake only they
have the knowledge
and global reach needed to reshape our
relationship
with our oceans helping them achieve
this
is the most powerful thing we can do to
keep our oceans alive
thank you